Joe Biden has a new way to screw you
over and it's all in the name of equity
if you're saving up to buy a new home
the president is going to make you pay
for someone else's too his
administration is rolling out a new plan
that punishes people who have good
credit in many cases they will now have
to pay forty dollars more per month in
order to subsidize loans for a higher
risk borrowers industry experts warn it
will backfire one says quote it's going
to be a challenge trying to explain to
somebody that says quote I worked my
whole life for a high credit score and I
put a lot of money down and now you're
telling me that's a negative that's a
hard conversation to have
okay you know uh Joey I heard you saying
that you're just buying a new home and
in the last mortgage crisis uh mortgages
were given to people who couldn't afford
them I think that was in 2008 how did
that work out for us well in 2008 a lot
of people were buying houses to put
renters in them so they weren't buying
them to live in uh I think the
difference now is people people are
trying to find somewhere to live there
is a housing problem there is a places
to live problem
um and you know haraldo and I were
talking about the VA loan program going
in or during the commercial break and
there's an interesting aspect there you
don't have to pay a down payment you
usually get a good interest rate maybe
not the best but the process is way more
stringent and that's a benefit you
earned so rather than penalizing
everyone who's worked hard to have good
credit literally taking money from them
why not create programs similar to that
for people that can earn it if it's
teachers or doctors or nurses maybe you
can take care of a lot of these middle
class people that have had to rack up
credit card debt but are paying their
bills by simply providing a program that
maybe the banks even take some of the
risk rather than the taxpayer and the
federal government would Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac buying up every long well
you know the the bottom line Dana is
that they're Pond they're punishing
responsible homeowners in an effort to
bring in new buyers who don't have a
credit score to get a a loan on their
own and you know it kind of smacks of
socialism I actually like I said how are
these new rules not anything other than
socialism yeah and from 2008 I was the
press secretary then I still have the
you know tire marks on my back trying to
explain what a credit default swap was
and it's just it's really hard to
believe
that this is happening again yeah
because if you think about Obama and
Biden when they were in the White House
under as President and Vice President
what's the first thing they did every
day is they got up and they had to blame
George W bush for the mortgage crisis
the mortgage crisis one of the reasons
is because you had people who were not
ready or not able to have the expensive
homes that they were in they couldn't
pay the rate and then all of it came
crashing down so I feel like Biden could
write this book of how to stoke populist
anger and lose re-election because what
came out of the mortgage crisis the Tea
Party
after the Tea Party what did you have
then you bring then Donald Trump comes
on the scene and it's like wait a second
and he's speaking to people the way that
they feel and I think that this is a
similar thing on the student loan crisis
the White House blows it off the numbers
are very clear I think it's one of the
reasons the numbers his poll numbers
aren't that great they don't actually
attack any problem to solve it they just
paper over it with more regulations this
one was sneaky very sneaky all of a
sudden this is happening people are
going to be very angry about it it's not
that you haven't heard the end of it how
do you think this is going to impact the
overall economy that's in a mess that 69
percent of Americans think is a mess I
don't know if it's going to have that
big an impact on the overall economy but
I I do think that it Harkens back to the
student loan the inequity the sense that
I paid my back you're not going to pay
us back it's unfair and I think that a
lot of people given the you know the
fact that you are rewarded for a low
credit score and you penalize for a good
credit it's kind of like putting the
world uh ass backwards in the sense
excuse my language but uh it just uh I I
don't like it and it's not a lot of
money and it's it's just enough money to
annoy you if you have a four hundred
thousand dollar mortgage which is a very
substantial house uh I mean for for most
working of middle class people
so it's 40 bucks on top of your your
payment 40 bucks a month a month I mean
I I I think for now it's a no it's
annoying I don't think it helps uh Joe
Biden I'm not sure it will help uh the
the prospective homeowners it was a
catastrophe in 2008 right the subprime
mortgages uh given to people who put no
money down my dad always used to say and
he got the the GI Bill and then so we
had ten thousand dollar house uh but he
always used to say that you have to put
money down to feel a sense of uh
investment uh of uh of being part of
something wonderful in America uh and
without any money down without that kind
of responsibility I don't I'm not sure
this is a very good idea you know I've
even read some some articles Greg that
talk about it may go up to a hundred
dollars a month on that four hundred
thousand dollar mortgage so the question
is do you get to count the people uh
that your money is going towards to help
them as dependents that would be good if
you look if you do the math right now
it's 500 bucks a year 30-year fixed rate
mortgage uh let me do my
equal fifteen thousand dollars over the
course of the loan so if you go to 100
then you're talking probably more thirty
thousand I I'm just that was math I like
that yeah yeah you know what's funny I
mean the thing is I mean it is 40 bucks
that's still like a a good cheap dinner
for the mom and dad at Applebee's but
also I mean that's how the government
does it they nickel and dime you they
open the door a little and then they
start pushing it pretty soon it's 100
bucks and it's 200 bucks it doesn't
matter yeah it's a principle of it yeah
principle very good also nobody
complained about Biden the rates are
went from three to six under his
administration
but the bigger the bigger thing right
now what are we gonna do about the the
corporate real estate yeah these cities
are like San Francisco 40 empty
corporate and uh so the thing is I mean
it's like I remember when when people
were moving from New York to to uh
Florida and you had de Blasio and these
other people were saying ah good luck
Good Riddance we don't need you
this this is bad I mean if this is your
tax base
nobody's going to be renting these giant
buildings and who's gonna who's gonna
get nailed the banks who made these
loans which means what which means we
are allowed yeah we're in uh
a lot of the offices but the thing is
what person is going to want to move to
a place that's dangerous like you know
what I mean yeah nobody hi winner Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now